hi guys is a drought from simply learn
and today we are going to talk about ten
programming languages that you should
look out for in 2019 now without further
ado let's get to number 10 PHP no PHP
was created in 1990 by this person
called Rasmus lured off and is a
language that works with a wide number
of operating systems like UNIX windows
linux and so on so regardless of the
operating system PHP has you covered so
PHP was created keeping in mind that it
should be an efficient way for database
management and it reduces web
development time and finally PHP has a
very supportive and dedicated user
community where you can connect with in
case you have some trouble with the
language now let's talk about some of
the features of PHP the PHP is an
interpreted language so most programming
languages require each line of code be
converted to machine code in the
compliation process that's not required
at PHP which makes it naturally faster
then it provides real-time access
monitoring and is faster than other
scripting languages like ASP and JSP now
one very unique feature of PHP is that
it's both a general-purpose programming
language as well as it's a scripting
language for server-side scripting and
finally all keywords classes functions
and use the functions are not
case-sensitive in PHP which means when a
function is being called in your code
regardless of whether the functions name
is enough of case all lowercase it will
mean the same thing however it's not the
same thing when it comes to variables
they are case sensitive now let's look
at some of the applications of PHP so
PHP is but found widespread usage
amongst several websites as it's clearly
seen 82% of all websites on the internet
use PHP for server-side programming
it also supports multiple databases like
MySQL Oracle and number of protocols
like le AP and pop3 it helps your data
to be processed in a graphical form for
example charts and graphs with the help
of tools like image graph and now let's
go to number 9 ruby now ruby was created
in the mid-1990s by Yukihiro Matsumoto
ruby is also the basic groundwork for
other frameworks like Ruby on Rails
which is a web application framework so
the creators of Ruby
so made sure that the language is
expressive and easy to understand and
finally users are provided more than
60,000 libraries and multiple frameworks
for them to use now let's talk about
some of Rudys features ruby is a free
format language you can start writing
code from any line or column basically
from anywhere you see on the terminal
next it's case sensitive which means
something that's written in lowercase is
completely different from something
that's written in uppercase it is a
dynamic programming language which means
also the type checking and all that
takes place during runtime and there are
set of loose out key words that cannot
be used for anything else other than
what they were created for they have a
specific purpose and cannot be used for
anything else
now let's talk about some of the
applications of Ruby firstly it's used
for server-side scripting and
configuration management it's also used
as framework where there are servers and
they need to convert their domain names
to IP addresses it's also used in
embedded systems and mending machines
industrial robots and network routers
and finally it is also used for creating
native applications for the iOS and the
Android operating systems and now let's
have a look at number eight Scala
now Scala was created in the early 2000s
by martin order scheme now Scala
supports both object-oriented and
functional programming with
object-oriented the main emphasis is on
objects which is a combination of data
and the functionality that's acting on
the data with functional programming
like the name suggests the main emphasis
is on the functions rather than the data
you can do both with Scala now Scala was
designed to solve the problems that
we're faced by Java for example one
common complaint is that Java is very
verbose or has a lot of lines of code if
a particular program required 20 lines
of code to complete in Java Scala would
be able to do it in much lesser but a
slightly more complicated version of the
same lines of code users also have
access to the features of the Java
Virtual Machine and several Java
libraries now let's have a look at some
of the features provided by Scala
firstly it's a statically typed language
which means that once you set a type for
a variable you can't change it again it
can be compiled into Java bytecode and
executed in the Java Virtual Machine as
it requires fewer lines of code it helps
speed up development testing and deploy
your application and finally it has a
steeper learning curve than other
programming languages which means it's
slightly more complex and requires
slightly more effort to understand it
now let's talk about some of the
applications of Scala it is used
extensively in a magic spark which means
it's used for data analysis and other
machine learning algorithms it is used
to create web applications and services
and helps improve runtime stability
performance and the overall developer
productivity now let's have a look at
number seven our pod was created in 1992
by Ross Rocca and Robert gentlemen so R
is an open source programming language
which means that you can access the
source code and perform any
modifications you require on the
language it provides an environment for
implementing statistical techniques R is
a commonly used language when it comes
to mathematical applications and can be
compiled on a wide range of operating
systems be it UNIX windows or mac OS now
let's talk about some of its features
our has a wide range of tools that can
be used for data analysis which is one
of the more common use cases of our our
supports object-oriented programming as
well as procedure oriented programming
which means depending on your situation
you can use either it provides data
handling and storage facilities and as
an interpreted language just like PHP as
mentioned before and can be accessed
through CLI or a command-line
interpreter now let's talk about some of
the applications of our first it can be
used for statistical computing and
graphics you can make plots or graphs or
charts with mathematical symbols and
formulae it can be used for data
importing and cleaning for sales
forecasting sentiment analysis cancer
detection and so on now let's have a
look at number 6 the programming
language Go Go is created in 2007 at
Google go reportedly works faster than
most programming languages in the market
right now
it has a strong standard library which
provides a wide range of options for its
users and created by developers who have
a shared dislike for C++ mainly because
they felt that C isn't fast enough and
needs to be faster now let's talk about
some of the features of go now
go has built-in systems which makes sure
that testing is made a whole lot easier
they have inbuilt testing support with
this
it aims to improve programming
productivity so it also provides easier
memory management as compared to other
programming languages like C and C++ and
finally the corn go is compiled into
machine code which makes it much faster
to execute as compared to other
programming languages now let's talk
about some of the applications of go
firstly it's used in distributed
applications that require a large amount
of processing power it is also used to
create applications that can be used to
scrape data from websites it enables
creating websites that can offer both
static as well as dynamic content and
finally it enables easy modification
debugging and testing of micro services
now let's have a look at number 5 swift
swift was created by Apple in the year
2010 and has codes that closely
resembles English and is easily readable
for users
now one main advantage that Swift offers
to users is that it provides a special
area where new applications can be
tested without having to actually create
a new application and it was also open
source which enables it to be constantly
updated and improved now let's talk
about some of the features offered by
Swift now as you write code in Swift
it's being fixed so in case there are
issues you're getting them fixed as you
write the code this reduces the amount
of time and money required to fix the
error it enables users to develop apps
which have a mixed codebase which means
there's a combination of different codes
of different languages it uses high
performance compilers which is used to
convert the Swift code into its native
form and finally it provides a clean and
expressive language with simple syntax
now let's talk about some of the
applications made possible with sift you
can develop applications for iOS Mac OS
T version watch West basically for Apple
it's used in online compilers and
websites and is used to create web
frameworks for websites and applications
now let's have a look at number 4 Java
Java is created on May 23rd 1995 now it
is one of the most commonly learned and
used languages in the world more than 3
billion mobile phones in the world use
Java for its proper functioning and Java
was created with the aim
of being platform-independent which
means regardless of the system that you
using Java will work in it now let's
talk about some of the features that
Java offers now Java is very similar to
C and C++ but also is quite different in
a way it removes all the complexities
and drawbacks that C++ and C have for
example Java doesn't have pointers Java
also utilizes all the features of
object-oriented programming like
abstraction encapsulation and so on the
security systems in Java are built into
the language and runtime systems and
finally the code in Java is converted
into byte code and allows it to be run
in any other system as long as that
system has Java in it and now let's talk
about some of the applications made
possible with Java
now applications for Android phones are
made possible with jdk or the java
development kit
simcards utility meters televisions also
used embedded java technologies within
them it is used for web applications
with the help of servlets struts and
jsps and is used for writing
applications that involve mathematics or
complex scientific calculations and now
let's have a look at number three
c-sharp c-sharp was created in 2000 by
Microsoft is the fourth most popular
programming language among users now it
follows the principles of
object-oriented programming and enables
fast development and has a large number
of inbuilt functions that users can take
advantage of now let's have a look at
some of the features offered by C shop
now C shop works with the structured
approach which means that the problem is
divided into each part and then solved
now as long as you know how to work with
C++ C shop should be very easy you can
do the same things possible with the C++
application it provides automatic
scaling and updates and derives most of
its principles from C++ and Java now
let's have a look at some of the
applications made possible with the C
shop now it is used along with
applications like ASP for web
development it is used in the Unity game
development engine and is used for
developing Windows desktop applications
and now for number two JavaScript
JavaScript was created on December 4th
1995
and provides users with the option to
select both functional or
object-oriented programming
methodologies so depending on the users
requirement they can choose either it
provides both
our site as well as front-end coding and
as long as you know JavaScript you can
handle any layer of a web application
now let's talk about some of the
features of JavaScript it's a simple
language that users can learn and
implement with great ease it provides a
rich and detailed interface for websites
it can also be used in combination with
other programming languages like Perl
and PHP and in neighbors websites to
provide increased functionality now
let's talk about some of the
applications of JavaScript this allows
users to create webpages and
applications it is used to create small
scale games and applications as well it
enables users to add text boxes and
other components to websites on the goat
and finally we are at number one it
shouldn't be any surprise because it's
Python Python was created in December
1989 and has easier syntax as compared
to other programming languages like Java
it has a very dedicated and supportive
community that can ease any of your
problems and it's designed with the
perspective of the developer which means
the initiative is developer first now
let's talk about some of its features
it's very easy to understand simple and
minimalistic now it supports procedure
oriented programming as well as object
oriented programming it also provides
scripting capabilities when embedded
with other programming languages like C
or C++ with the help of dynamic
programming offered by Python executions
are also made a whole lot easier now
let's have a look at some Python
applications it is used for scientific
as well as numeric computing for example
with the help of libraries like Sai pipe
pandas and so on it is used for image
processing and graphic design
applications it plays a very important
role in Linux distributions and it's
used for creating web applications and
frameworks and with that we've reached
the end of another video I hope you guys
found this informative and helpful thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simply loved
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here